[MUSIC PLAYING]
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Hello.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
That's a good start.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: So we are
Zach and Kelly Weinersmith,
and we wrote a book
called "SOONISH,
10 Emerging Technologies
That Will Improve and/or Ruin
Everything."
I'm a parasitologist.
I study parasites
that manipulate
the behavior of their hosts,
and I work for Rice University.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: And I
draw comics and stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY WEINERSMITH: So we decided
to write a book on technology.
And in 2011, a group of policy
students at Hamilton College
wrote a book called--
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Oh, it was a paper.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: A
paper, sorry, called
"Are Talking Heads
Blowing Hot Air?"
And essentially,
they were looking
at the predictive abilities
of 26 really popular pundits
that were on lots of TV shows.
And these pundits
ranged from being
mostly right to mostly wrong.
But importantly, they
all still had their jobs.
And so we were like, we should
write a book about tech.
where it doesn't matter if
we're right or wrong because,
apparently, that doesn't impact
your ability to have a job.
But actually, we're not
really interested in this book
in making predictions because
we think that what's interesting
isn't necessarily figuring out
how many years out a technology
is, so much just
talking about what
the amazing challenges that
people are working on right now
are.
And so we talk a lot more
about the technical hurdles
that still need to be overcome.
And then we talk a
little bit about how
these technologies could make
everything awesome but also
maybe horrible.
And so, we give you a
little bit of a taste of one
of the chapters in the book and
a little bit on one of the nota
benes.
What did want to say?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Oh, OK.
So the 10 topics we
cover in the book--
let's see if I can
remember them all--
are cheap access to space,
asteroid mining, fusion,
brain-computer interfaces,
bioprinting, augmented reality,
robotic construction,
programmable matter--
ZACH WEINERSMITH: BCI.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
Brain-Computer Interfaces, I
thought I said that already.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
And then bioprinting.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
And bioprinting.
Didn't I say bioprinting?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I said both of those already.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: So we're
still on eight now, huh?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: That's fine.
Anyway, buy the book.
You'll find out the rest.
That's our pitch.
And at the end of a
lot of the chapters,
we uncovered all
sorts of crazy stuff
while we were doing the
research for this book.
And that's a ton, a big part of
why this book was so much fun
to write.
And so, at the end of
some of the chapters,
we talk about these weird
things that we encountered,
and we include these
in our nota benes.
And so we're going to
discuss one of the nota benes
that we wrote in
the book as well.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It's not this
one, but this is a whole thing.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: This
was really awesome.
And we've got to talk to
so many amazing people
while doing this book.
But anyway, so we've been told
that, instead of talking about
cheap access to space,
programmable matter
would probably go over
best with this audience.
So we're doing the
programmable matter chapter.
So how about you start?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Oh, I'll start?
OK.
Sure.
So I feel like I
need to not talk
too much because it's
Google, so I don't need
to explain what are computers.
I guess, right?
You all know about those?
Yeah.
So the idea in general
with programmable matter
is that, in the same way
that a computer is universal,
you can make stuff
that's universal.
And there are a lot of
different approaches
to how you might do that.
I think we go through
a couple of them here.
The book's a lot more extensive.
But when we say
programmable matter,
we're kind of
condensing together
a bunch of different fields
like self-reconfiguring matter.
There's a book called
"Morphogenetic Engineering,"
and I wish they'd
gone with that.
That was really cool.
But just stuff that
can reconfigure itself
in different ways.
So we're going to go
through a few ways.
This is a little wordy.
So this is my drawing
of Skyler Tibbits.
Skyler Tibbits is a guy at MIT.
He does what it calls
4D printing, which
just means it's 3D
printing but the stuff
does more once it's printed.
So there are a bunch
of examples of this,
but one we thought was cute
was he made this straw,
and it's just made to the joints
are printed so that when intake
water they bend in a way
that you, quote unquote,
"program into the materials."
So he made one
where you program it
so you drop the stick
in water and it spells
at MIT because he's at MIT.
But what's cute about
that, we thought,
is you could really
creep people out
if they didn't know what it was.
[LAUGHTER]
You could make
programmable spaghetti,
it just says like,
find help or something.
I don't know.
There's another one that's
theoretically more functional.
I don't think the wood
thing was his, right?
That was?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Right.
Yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: So
there's this one project
where it was essentially
wood that was designed
to respond to humidity.
And so it was like you can
give a building basically
pores so that they can open
out or close up depending
on ambient conditions.
So there are a couple of
projects working on that.
And in addition to just
kind of looking awesome,
you have the potential for zero-
or low-energy environmental
regulation mechanism, but
mostly it looks really cool.
It looks like you're looking
at like a giant dead alien,
so that's neat.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
So one of the things
that Skyler Tibbits
pointed out was
that the hard thing about
this technology right
now is that there isn't
really good software written
that programs in
information about joints
and how they respond to
environmental conditions.
And I know you guys
have like 20% of time
that you get to spend on
anything else, so FYI.
So then, the next category
that we talk about
are origami robots.
And we got really excited
about origami and robots,
and so we had this guy
Jason Ku design an origami--
what?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Robot.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Robot.
OK, robot.
But anyway, so if
you're interested
in our origami robot, you
can download the design here
and you can see
our origami robot.
So origami, I'm sure you're
all familiar with origami.
You have a sheet
of paper and you
follow like some rules
for how you fold it,
and you make it be
this different shape.
Well, if you also put
actuators in there,
you can get the
paper to fold itself
so that you don't have
to do it on your own
because why spend
the time doing that.
It's really frustrating,
I know some people
think it's beautiful.
That's probably not me.
And so, anyway, you can put
these actuators in there.
With these actuators,
you can get the robots
to walk around and
pick stuff up and do
all sorts of crazy stuff.
What were you going to say?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: No, no.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Oh, OK.
So one of the cool
things that they're
working on getting
these robots to do
is have medical applications.
So Dr. Daniela Rus at MIT
made this origami robot out
of sausage casing.
And you, essentially,
fold it up.
You stick it in ice.
The person swallows the ice.
And then, the origami bot, when
the ice dissolves, pops out.
And then, you can
control it with a magnet.
And apparently-- this number
blew my mind-- apparently,
3,500 people every year
swallow those batteries
that you find in watches.
And having a
three-and-a-half-year-old
and a one-year-old, I'm guessing
that they're all people under
five.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I think
it's mostly children.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
It's mostly children.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: But a couple
of people with certain tastes.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Sure.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
And so what this robot does--
some percent of
those 3,500 people
end up with the battery lodged
in part of their stomach,
and they can't get it out
and then you have problems.
If it passes, you're fine.
But if it gets stuck,
you have problems.
So this robot goes in,
opens up, and then you
control it with a magnet.
It connects to the battery.
It yanks it out to dislodge it.
And then it passes
with everything else
and leaves naturally.
And so we're hoping that
that little robot never
really develops the ability to
consider its life objectively
because it might be
a little depressed.
But again, it's sausage casing.
So it's going to
dissolve away, and it's
going to go away, so you don't
have to worry about going
over it feels about things.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Because it'll be dead.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
And so anyway, that's one use,
but Daniella is hoping that,
first of all, at some point,
you won't have to control it
remotely, it'll
work on its own .
And then, she's also working
on other things like,
can you get these bots
to deliver medicine
to very particular areas?
And so she's thinking about
the medical applications.
But you can also make
these things big enough
that it could be like a table
that, if someone's disabled,
the table puts itself together
and then walks over to you
so you don't have to go to
it, or a chair that can just
fold up together and go
to where it needs to go.
And so you can see or
you can imagine lots
of cool applications for that.
Go ahead.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: So the
super-advanced paradigm
that may never happen is called
the bucket-of-stuff paradigm,
which is something
like this, perhaps.
But the basic idea is it's
kind of like having a T-1000,
but it fixes stuff in your
house instead of killing you.
But if it's truly
universal, it should
be able to turn into anything.
It could be a wrench.
It could be a phone.
If you can command it
and it's on your side,
you can just tell it to glob
over and do something for you.
So there are a lot of
problems with this paradigm,
and the privacy
thing is one actually
that we'll probably
get to in a little bit.
But we had a couple of people
actually working on this.
The big problem is, I
think the smaller one was
like a cubic centimeter.
You have these little quote
unquote "atoms" that can move,
can sense a little bit,
can dock with each other.
That's important.
And then, after that, some
of the stuff it's luxury.
You might want a battery
on board each one.
So miniaturizing this is
a really tough problem.
And then, I get into the
math thing a little bit.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
That's right now.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Oh, god.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
The time is now.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yes.
So one of the really
interesting things we found out
is that one of the difficulties
of building a T-1000
to serve you is the math because
I think the way we say it is,
if you imagine you
have a marching band
that's got a shape
from say a star
and do the university
logo, and say
you only have 100 people,
that's not that hard a problem.
Plus, each atom of that
system has a human brain,
so that helps.
But it's not that
a hard problem,
but you imagine each time
you add another individual,
the problem doesn't just
get one person harder.
It scales.
So if it's 1,000, that
becomes a really hard problem,
people knowing where to go, what
to do if someone falls over.
And then if you scale it
10,000 or a million or I guess
the T-1000 would have a
billion and they're in three
dimensions, and presumably
they're all sort of physical
constraints at each point-- like
along the equivalent of a bone
you have to all be docked with
each other a certain way--
what happens is calculating
what everybody needs
to do to make your
hand into a giant knife
to kill that one
guy in the movie--
I shouldn't be talking
about the T-1000.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: You know way
too little about that movie,
also.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: So you want
to do that, it's actually
a pretty tough math problem.
You have to expend just
the right amount of atoms.
They all have to get
to the right place.
And crucially, if you
really want to kill a human,
they have to go fast.
So there's a version that
super-preliminary version
that's called Kilobots, which if
want to visualize it's little,
almost the size
of a watch battery
canister with three little legs.
And it kind of
moves by jiggling.
And they're called Kilobots
because the original system
had 1,024 of them--
not 1,000 because
it's nerd town.
But yes, 1,024 of these.
And being aware of
this sort of problem,
they wanted to have a
relatively simple algorithm
that each of them were using.
And so they did
get it where they
could shape like a wrench--
not when you could ever use, but
a 2D shape of a wrench and then
change into, say, a
star or something.
The problem was, I think it
was like it took six hours
to go from one to the other.
So they had this really sort
of simple perimeter crawling
algorithm.
And again, if you want
to kill somebody or have
a phone instantly
appear in your hand
and then have a kill somebody--
[LAUGHTER]
You're going to have a problem
unless you solve this math
problem.
I don't know.
It might not even be solvable,
or at least not solvable
in the sense of getting a way
to do it quickly and properly.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: But this
audience can solve it probably.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
20% of your time
to the robot murderer, yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
So there are a lot
of reasons why a bucket of
stuff could be a problem.
So an ideal bucket
of stuff would
be able to become like
a camera or a receiver,
and it could
transmit information.
And if these get
really tiny, you
could imagine that it would be
very easy to spy on someone.
You just put some of these
in all the hotel rooms,
and then you can spy on everyone
and transmit that information
anywhere.
And then additionally, if you
can get this bucket of stuff
to look like anything,
you could make
it look like you're
clothes, and then you
could bring it on
in flight and then
you could turn it into
something more dangerous.
And so, presumably,
the TSA would
be trying to keep the
bucket of stuff out,
but it's hard to know
how they would be
able to do something like that.
So then, you talked about
there's privacy concerns.
And then there's
patenting concerns.
So if you have a bucket of
stuff that can become anything,
then why buy anything else?
You can just tell your bucket
of stuff to become that thing.
So it's hard to know how that
problem is going to be solved,
although 3D printing
is sort of starting
to deal with those
problems now kind of.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
No, a little bit.
There's this issue of,
can you 3D print a gun?
And that's a tough one.
More importantly,
it's like people
can't make gun laws if you
can always 3D print a gun.
But if you have
programmable matter,
it's like you have a permit
anything device that includes
all sorts of banned things.
So yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Well,
then, another problem
is, who is to blame when
something goes wrong?
And, of course, this is the
self-driving car problem.
If your self-driving car
gets into an accident,
who do you blame?
And so there are proposals
that you could use.
So they have 4D printing stuff
that we were talking about.
So maybe you could use that to
change the way airplane wings
work depending on the
speed that you're going at,
or maybe you could use it to
change your tires depending
on the conditions.
But what happens if
one of those things
goes wrong at the wrong
moment and you die?
Who's to blame for that?
Is it the person
who designed it?
And so, anyway, these decisions,
these sorts of problems
need to get worked out.
Any other negatives?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I think
Skylar Tibbits talked
about a sort of general
negative of offloading
our personal autonomy
to machines that
just make decisions for us.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Oh,
we've already done that.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: OK.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
That's not a problem.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
That's true, yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
No, I'm kidding.
So anyway, so then there is a
number of different benefits
if you have this kind of stuff.
So one, presumably we could
really cut down on waste.
So if you had a bucket
that could become anything,
then you could own
a lot less stuff
because that bucket could become
your wrench and your plunger.
So you don't need
a big tool kit.
You've got this thing that
could become anything.
We already talked
a little bit about
how, if you have stuff on your
home that changes in response
to ambient conditions,
you could maybe
control internal conditions with
very low energy input, which
we think is pretty exciting.
Then we talked about
the programmable matter,
like those little
origami robots which
could help deliver medicine
to very particular locations
or dislodge batteries.
Anything else?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Anymore awesomeness?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: There's tons.
Mostly, I want a
toy origami thing.
I don't know.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: A toy origami
thing would be pretty awesome.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Thanks.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
You're welcome.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
So one version we
don't really talk
about in a second
I think is the
swarm robots version
of how you might do that.
It's kind of related to
how a T-1000 would work.
I keep coming back to that.
But there are
practical utilities
to having like a large swarm
of robots that can reconfigure
with each other because
if you want to, say, send
a bunch of robots
into a disaster zone
a swarm might be
preferable to just one
because, if something
breaks down, it would be OK.
And also, by being able to break
apart and come back together,
they can navigate a
little more effectively.
So we looked at one
group It's something
like you'd have 10
robots about this big,
and one of the
tricks they could do
is navigate through
like a dip in the ground
by latching onto each other.
And so they had this
really cute algorithm where
one robot realizes there's
a big dip, and then it
I think on that one it
was a lighting system.
So it signaled, hey,
someone docked with me.
And then, the other robots
would get the signal.
They'd back up until they had a
train of the appropriate size,
and then they could
go over the gap.
There are all sorts of similar
things you can program in.
They could effectively
tightrope walk or at least
cross a narrow passage by
having two side by side
going the right way.
Also, can I talk about
the evolving robot thing?
I know it's not
germane to the talk.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Well,
we've got to get to the--
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
All right, all right.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
Maybe at the end.
Someone can ask about that.
But in general, if you
have this swarm that
can solve its own
problems as it goes,
you can send it into hazardous
areas like New Jersey
and have it solve
problems and fix things.
But to be honest, what we
were most excited about
was imagine you
go to IKEA and you
buy that table and the
table just unfolds itself
and you don't have
to put it together.
That would save like
a billion human hours
if you didn't have to put
together your IKEA stuff.
So we're going to talk
about the nota bene
on how it will end
for all of humanity.
So we came across a lot
of really awesome stories
about human-robot interactions
that made us not particularly
optimistic about humanity's
ability to persist
in the face of smart robots.
So do you want to talk
about Promobot first?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Sure, sure.
So Promobot-- I'm definitely
pronouncing it wrong.
I'm not going to try it.
It's a Russian robot company.
And this is just a little
sort of-- it was cute.
There's this robot,
and it was designed
to be like a robot assistant.
It can do things like
remember human faces
and learn things
about its environment.
And it apparently
keeps trying to escape.
[LAUGHTER]
So they had, what
was it, two incidents
where it got out and
ran down the street?
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
And it ran out
of batteries in the
middle of the road.
So instead of
helping the elderly
like I think it was
supposed to be doing,
it instead died in the middle of
the street and stopped traffic.
So we need our
robots to stop trying
to escape because they're
not very helpful there.
But then, our favorite
robot was named Gaia.
So there was a Harvard
undergrad named Serena Booth,
and she wanted to know how
much people trust robots.
And so she lived in
the dorms, and there
are a number of
different reasons
why if you live in
Harvard dorms you
shouldn't be letting anything
or anyone into the dorms.
So first of all,
apparently-- and this
totally creeps me out--
apparently at Harvard,
tourists like to
take photos of dorms.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Like
the inside of them?
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
The inside of dorms.
So they'll come up
to the dorm window.
You're shaking your head.
Did that happen to you?
Were you at Harvard?
AUDIENCE: Just a
lot of universities.
We have it at Google, too.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: What the
heck is wrong with people?
So anyway, they come
up to the window
and they put the camera
up and they take a photo.
So people are trying to
intrude on privacy all the time
if you're in these dorms.
And then, additionally,
the Harvard dorms
that had bomb threats
somewhat recently--
so everyone had been
written recently and told,
do not let anyone
into the dorms.
They didn't specify no
robots, but they probably
assumed you shouldn't
be letting anything in.
And then, finally, there
were a bunch of thefts.
So the students knew you
shouldn't be letting anyone
to the dorms.
So what Serena did is she
created a robot that she
could operate remotely.
So she was sitting at a table
pretending to do her work,
but she was really
operating this robot.
And it would come up to
people first by themselves
and say, hey, can let
you me into the dorm?
And I think something like 21%
of the time they'd say yes,
but usually they'd be like no,
you can't get in the dorms.
But if the robot approached
groups, 71% of the time
they let it in.
So notes to any
robots out there,
humans are real dumb in groups.
And then, additionally, if
she gave the robot cookies,
almost everyone let it in.
And so it was carrying a box
from a fancy local cookie
chain, but it actually only
had grocery store, crummy
snickerdoodle cookies in there.
And so, apparently, for
the price of like dollar
snickerdoodles, people will
put their entire dorm at risk
to let the cookies in.
Do you want to talk about
the emergency robots,
or do you want me to?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I think
you're more the expert on that.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: OK.
So finally, there was a PhD
student named Paul Robinette,
and he was at Georgia
Institute of Technology.
And he wanted to know how
much people would trust robots
in an emergency situation.
So first, he started off
with sort of like low stakes.
There were some
undergrads who thought
they were doing a survey.
So they came in, and
the robot brought them
to the survey room.
And they did the survey,
and then the experimenters
released smoke and set
off the fire alarms.
And a lot of the undergrads,
instead of going out
the door that they
just came in--
so they knew how to get
out of the building--
followed the robot.
At first, we were like,
well, that's weird.
And then, we watched the
video, and it was really weird
because that is a
slow-moving robot.
It was just like crawling along.
But it gets worse.
So then, they had
a situation where
the robot went to the wrong
room and circled the wrong room
and then went to
the survey room--
again, moving real slow.
And then, they did
the thing again.
And still, most
of the undergrads
follow that robot
instead of going out
the door that they knew.
And then, finally, there
was a last treatment
with I think only six students,
so it's a small sample size.
But the robot went into
a corner and started
going like this-- like this
is where the survey is.
And an experimenter came
out and said, I'm sorry,
this robot is broken.
They use the words,
And then they went
to a different room
to do the survey.
And they set off
the smoke alarm,
and some students followed it.
And then, I think
Paul was like, I'm
just going to see how
far I can push this.
And so, in one situation,
he had the robot
go to her room that
was blocked by a couch,
all the lights were shut off,
and there was no exit sign.
And the robot started
pointing at the dark room,
and there were students who
had to be retrieved eventually
by the experimenters because
they would not leave the robot.
So anyway, this blows my mind.
So this robot looked
really not human-like.
It was a very
dumb-looking, slow robot.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Trash can on wheels.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
Paul did a great job,
but it looks like a
trash can on wheels.
So the point is, you don't
need a T-1000 to trick humanity
to their doom.
It just needs to be
a trash can on wheels
that's carrying
cookies and humanity
is in a lot of trouble.
And so, if the robots ever rise
up, we're done for perhaps.
But so, anyway, that's
just a taste of one
of the chapters in the
book and one of the nota
benes that we did.
We did 10 chapters, eight of
which we've told you about.
Maybe we'll remember if you
ask use a question about it.
We only spent two years on this.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Asteroid mining.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: I said that.
[LAUGHTER]
Synthetic biology and
precision medicine.
10.
Anyway, shouldn't have
been so excited about that.
So anyway, that is
the book, and we
hope you enjoy it, those of
you who decide to read it.
And we would be happy
to answer questions now.
So if you want to line
up at the microphone,
we would love to hear what you
would like to ask us about.
Or, we can tell you about
cheap access to space.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: No, no.
We got some humans.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a
big fan of the comic.
Zach, you look exactly
like your picture.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: But
he's stressed right now.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Yeah,
which I make him do in public.
AUDIENCE: So I
preordered the book,
and I finally
received it yesterday.
And I actually only
received two bookplates.
So if you want one
back to give it
to another eligible purchaser.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: No, no.
You can keep the sticker
AUDIENCE: Actually,
I was curious.
I only got through
the first chapter,
and I was a little disappointed
to see that the space
elevator was already
in the first chapter
because I was looking
forward to that
to be the climax of the book.
Could you talk about how some
of these things interact?
So like the bucket of goo,
or the bucket of stuff,
could also be used
in space exploration.
You wouldn't have to
bring every possible tool.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I don't remember
if we talked about
that, but that was
one of the things brought up.
Actually, space comes up
surprisingly often in the book,
and we were trying
to figure out why.
I think our general realization
was that space is also
part of the universe.
So it's like you're still going
to eat most of the same stuff
once you're in space.
But yeah, you'll need it
much more efficiently.
So I think we talk
a little about it.
There's a little section in
the book on 3D-printed food
which they care about for space
kind of for the same reason.
It's efficient
food-packing mechanism.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
We talk a little bit
about recouping where
they're trying to figure out
how to reuse feces
and turn it back
into food in 3D print food.
But they're very efficient.
Yeah, exactly.
That face is the right face.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: The project
about using human waste
to feed humans contains the
phrase closing the loop--
[LAUGHTER]
Which I think gives you an
insight into food scientists.
We need to solve this.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Not all
loops need to be closed.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Gone on too long.
Sorry, did answer your question?
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It went
on a weird tangent, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this
is a question just
for Zach, are you intentionally
low-key cosplaying Shaggy?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Oh my god.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Oh my god.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I'm embarrassed.
AUDIENCE: Should we
have another question?
I thought she was going to--
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
That was more of an
assertion than a question.
I like your shirt, by the way.
AUDIENCE: So what was the
thing you wanted to talk about
with evolutionary robots?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: The what?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: The
Roombots that evolve.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Oh, go ahead.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: So OK.
You remember, we
talked about how
there's a one-centimeter
version of
the bucket-of-stuff paradigm.
There's a slightly more
currently plausible version
called Roombots, which is
totally worth looking up.
I use a search engine
called AltaVista.
[LAUGHTER]
We're talking at the one
guy at AltaVista next.
That's our next stop.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
But these Roombots,
you can visualize
like a thing about this big
that's really two hemispheres.
It's not literally spherical.
It's kind of like between
a sphere and a cube.
Why they do that is so
that an individual one
can kind of roll along.
And all they do, they
can detect things,
they can transmit and receive
signals, and they can dock.
And so the idea with
it is you basically
have these little things
that can roll around stick
to each other and they can
turn to light it's cold room
but because the idea
is to make furniture.
So for example, you
could have 20 of these.
They make the legs of the table.
And then one, literally,
would go grip a tabletop maybe
and then just sort
of carry it up--
because they can climb walls
and have the appropriate gripper
type--
and form a table.
And then, best of all, the
table can walk over to you.
It probably would
roll over to you,
but if you could get it to
walk, that would be really cool.
And so the nice
idea with this is
it would be good for
elder care, for people
who you can't do for
themselves as well as others.
But there's this
really cool project--
and I don't think,
I don't know if this
has been done in real life,
it's been done in simulations--
but the way genetic
algorithms work
is you would say that,
say, a pile of Roombots
configure somehow and go as
fast as you can across the room.
And then, once having done
that, you could mutate it.
And so people tried this.
And so what's really cool is
you can create a system that's
in real life made of
these individual robots,
and you can tell
them, hey, mutate
based on your last couple
versions that worked.
And maybe you arrive at
new design configurations
that you hadn't thought
of, which is just
kind of neat because it's
like genetic algorithms
but they're actually
having to interface
with reality instead of a
simulation, which, to me,
that's really cool.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
So now we have
to talk about the
swarm morph video.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Swarm morph?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: So
there was another group
that was doing
genetic algorithms
to try to get their similar
blocks to solve problems.
And we did not think that
this was necessary at all,
but someone directed
us to a video
where, before they would
try a new configuration,
they would come
together and then they
would rub against
each other for a while
as though they were mating.
And this went on
for like 25 seconds.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: That's right.
It sounded like some
administration person had said,
make them mate, and they
just taken it too literally.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Right.
And then. they'd essentially
just send directions
to a 3D printer, so it
was not at all necessary.
[LAUGHTER]
It was not a necessary
component of the process,
but it still did it anyway.
We took great joy in
watching that video.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I
forget about that, yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
anyway.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I
erased that, I don't know.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: It
was a little creepy.
I'll never forget.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
both for coming.
Huge fan of the comic strip.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Fairly often, there's
an extra, I guess bonus,
comic panel that
appears when you
hover over the votey button.
I assume this has some
historical import.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Very much so.
AUDIENCE: And actually, fairly
often in that pop-up panel,
it shows Kelly
disapproving often
holding one of your
children who is also
disapproving of the
content of the comic strip.
So I wonder if you
could speak a little bit
about the collaborative aspect.
Does she review every comic?
Would there be even
more offensive jokes
if she wasn't there
backstopping you?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
That's a good question.
Well, so I always tell my jokes,
and she makes notes on them.
And now and then, there's
one I think is really good
and that you hate, and
so I always do those.
[LAUGHTER]
Because, if it does well,
it's just such a win
in the marriage.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY WEINERSMITH: The
single-use monocles
was the number one
example of that.
I was like, that project's
never going to work.
That is stupid.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: They
may not know what it is.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: And
he sold tons of them.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: We
sold them in 25 packs.
So if you don't know, if you
go to singleusemonocles.com,
it's a real thing
you can actually buy.
It's like a wrapper
with one monocle.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: I
still don't get it.
I don't get it, but I'm glad
about the money it brought in.
So this is the nice thing
when it's a project like this.
So I might lose, but we
make money, and that's fine.
I'd rather win, actually.
There's no price that's
as important as winning,
but it's all right.
The money brings me some solace.
But what's interesting
is that I have met people
who have expected me to be super
grumpy and not a happy person,
and that is not me at
all I'm actually very--
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It's a lie.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: I'm
actually very upbeat.
And anyway, people expect
me to be kind of grumpy,
and I don't think I'm that
grumpy, but maybe I am.
Who knows?
AUDIENCE: Thank you?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
again, both, for coming.
Just out of curiosity, I
wondered what the process was
starting with the fan base
that was formed from single-use
monocles, there once was
a man from Schemonaria,
touch him on the
penis-style jokes--
which I've loved and got me
into your comic many, many years
ago--
and transition them
into much more science
and theory and intelligence.
Did you find any
friction there, or what
was the thought process going
from that style of humor
to this?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah, yeah.
So part of probably just
maturing a bit, but also just--
AUDIENCE: Boo.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I know, I know.
But I think I mistakenly
thought on the internet,
if you got nerdy, people
didn't like it too much.
I tried to keep it
a little, don't want
to send people to Wikipedia.
And it just turns out
that's totally wrong.
It seemed like the
dorkier the comic got,
the more sizable
the audience became.
So I just kept going
in that direction.
And also, as I got
to do it full time,
I just had more time to read
and get well up on things.
And that's been helpful.
But what's nice is I've
had a lot of people
say like, I started reading
your comic in high school,
and it's sort of grown with me.
So that's been very gratifying.
AUDIENCE: With everything
that's about to ruin everything,
how do we prepare the next
generation to survive?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Prepare them to survive.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Hey, I think
they're just doomed in use.
That's that.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Just let them go.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
Just teach them
that privacy doesn't matter.
That's something they're
going to have to deal with.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
We're not at Facebook.
You shouldn't--
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY WEINERSMITH: LOL.
I don't have a good
answer for that.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It would
be kind of topic dependent.
There are 10 different topics
and each presents issues.
So she mentions privacy,
which we talk about a bit more
extensively in a chapter on
brain-computer interfaces,
which are like the
final end of privacy
because now we can extract
brain states from a computer.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: You've
got to go into more detail.
Do you want me to
go into more detail?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Sure, yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: So
brain-computer interfaces
are little machines
that talk to your brain,
and they read your brain
waves and they figure out
what it is you're thinking
and what you want to do.
And right now,
they're being used
to make prosthetics that
will reach out and grab
the thing you're thinking about
reaching out and grabbing.
And we thought that
the end goal was
to make it so that someone
who was a quadriplegic
could have all
their abilities back
and, just by thinking about
it, they could do anything.
And so that's the
answer I expected
when I asked Gerwin
Schalk, what is
the end goal of
brain-computer interfaces?
And his answer was, one
day, all of our thoughts
will be able to get
uploaded to one cloud
and will become one
big superorganism that
shares all of our thoughts.
And I was like,
that is horrible.
Our marriage works because
that doesn't happen.
And I think that's why
society works in general.
And so he admitted that there
could be negatives to that.
He's like, if you're sitting
on the couch and you think,
I want to leave my wife,
she would know that.
And he said, and that
wouldn't be so great.
And I was like, that would
absolutely not be so great.
And so anyway, this is like
the ultimate end of privacy
if that ever happens.
And it is fascinating
to think about.
Humans are a totally different
thing if all of our brains
are connected like that.
Anyway, it's crazy, but
we personally kind of hope
that future never comes to pass
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Never happens, no.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: And
then, I asked other people
in the brain-computer interface
world, is this just Gerwin,
or does everybody know
that this is the end
goal but in interviews
you just talk
about being able to move your
arm if you couldn't before?
And they're like, well, yeah.
In the interviews, we
talk about the arm thing.
But at the conference,
we all know
that we're going to upload
or brain to the cloud.
And I was like, we need to
stop funding this field.
I'm very sorry for
the amputees, but--
ZACH WEINERSMITH: That's
going to get quoted somewhere.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: I hope not.
That would be very bad.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: You
know what's funny?
So I was just talking
at Google Seattle,
and somebody brought up, what
if instead of one there's three,
and now there is the
three-roommate problem?
There's like three superbrains.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
I'm not following.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: When two
are more down with each other
than the other superbrain.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Oh, got it.
So privacy, they really need
to not careful about privacy
if the future is going to work
for them because we're all
going to be one big superbrain.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've been reading SMBC
since I had to load it up
on a dial-up modem.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Oh my god.
What baud?
AUDIENCE: And that
was a big deal
because black-and-white
comics loaded a lot faster.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: That's right.
AUDIENCE: And I just was curious
what your favorite comic was?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Favorite of mine?
I kind of go through phases.
Probably one of the long
story ones or something,
but I don't really
have a favorite.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: I like xkcd.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
I'm not grumpy.
I have a nice personality.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
about the giraffe hooker?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Giraffe hooker?
For those who don't know--
that's a good start to that--
this is in reference, I
think there's an xkcd where
he made a joke about--
I don't actually remember
what the context was,
but the clear
implication was that I
needed to draw a sexy
giraffe as a bonus panel.
You're not aware of this?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: I forgot.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: So if you
want to see a sexy giraffe,
I'm one of your options.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY WEINERSMITH: It's funny.
So in grad school, I was a
faculty at Rice for a while.
And a lot of the people
I'd encounter, I'd be like,
oh, my husband's a cartoonist.
And everyone was like,
is it the xkcd guy?
No, no, no.
The PhD Comics guy?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
The PhD Comics guy.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
Not that either.
The SMBC guy.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: And
they just walk away.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: No, no.
That worked plenty
of times, also.
Thanks for your question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I find
it inspirational
that you're able to have
a relationship where
the two of you can be so
collaborative and creative.
I was wondering if
you had any tips.
[LAUGHTER]
Like tips to avoid ending
up on each other's nerves
or avoid having
one person taking
ownership of the project?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Ah,
well, so the background
is that, when we started
dating, our favorite thing to do
was spend all day in the
library and then go on walks
and talk about what
we had learned.
So our relationship started
as we'd like to go on walks
and talk about stuff.
And so this project,
essentially the topic
that we talked about on our
walks, was always "SOONISH."
Anyway, it was kind
of nice to know
we were talking about
different papers we
had read on the same topic.
And anyway, so that worked well.
But additionally,
we got kind of lucky
because our personalities
are such that we wanted
to tackle different parts.
So I did all of the interviews.
He did a lot of the
background reading,
although some of the
chapters that was me
doing the background reading.
He's the funny one, and so he
did the jokes and the comics.
And then I am
detail-oriented one,
so I went through every
single sentence in this book
and made sure we had a citation
for every single sentence.
This was when we
didn't actually think
that we were going to
write a bibliography, which
was real dumb of
us to not expect
that was going to happen.
And then Jenny, who's here,
was like, oh hey guys,
your bibliography.
I was like, ooh.
So I went through every sentence
and made our bibliography.
And that was something that
would have killed Zach.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yes.
I would have cried a lot.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
He would have cried.
And so I guess, to be
honest, we got lucky
that we're interested
in different parts of it
and that we really
just like talking
about nerdy stuff
for a long time
and sending chapters
back and forth.
It's really important to
not get your feelings hurt.
And I feel like in
any collaboration
that's really important.
But it's particularly
important when
it's your spouse who's like,
no, the synthetic biology
chapter you wrote is junk.
We've got to start over again.
And so you really need to have
a thick skin, which we both do.
Neither one of us cares
what the other one thinks.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
It's really important.
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
Do you have another answer?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Just a
little thing to add to that.
I do a decent amount
of collaborating,
and sometimes it goes well
and sometimes it doesn't.
And the two things that are
really important is, one,
you have separate magisteria
as much as possible.
You have separate roles,
and in your domain
you have more veto power
if not absolute veto power.
And the other thing-- and this
is hard to know in advance--
if the person you're working
with communicates well,
that makes a big
difference because people
who don't communicate
well end up
sort of storing up their
anger and then releasing it
on you at some point.
So if you have a relatively
mature person who
talks about when
they're having a problem
and doesn't just
try to tough it out,
that can be really helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Sure, thanks.
AUDIENCE: One of the
previous questions
reminded me that
my favorite SMBC
comic is the one
about how it takes
seven years to
master a new skill,
and that leads to
many lifetimes.
And you could be an
artist and a writer.
So can you talk about
the lifetimes you've had
and where that idea came from?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Oh man.
Perhaps some of you
have read, there's
a famous speech by Hamming
from, I think, 1986
that sort of talks about it.
It's actually written for
programmers about how you're
going to have your career.
And so he talked kind
of a related concept.
He talked about how he liked
switching fields a lot.
He was a very nerdy
guy, so I think
he was talking about switched
from software to hardware.
He wasn't talking about
like becoming a poet.
But I found that idea
really interesting
to keep you from going stale.
So this project was
kind of one of those.
And another one we started
doing five years ago
is called BAHFest, the
Festival of Bad Ad Hoc
hypotheses, which gives you
a pretty good sense of how
nerdy it is, which was and
remains a pretty big challenge.
It's a live event.
It's sort of an
improv game, I guess.
It's like fake
science talks that you
have to defend against
actual scientists.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
It's funny.
Every time we do a project
like this, at some point.
I have the same thought,
which is, why didn't I
just keep writing comics?
But yeah, I try
to on the regular
do something that like makes
me really uncomfortable.
I don't quite have the luxury
to completely switch careers
at any moment because we have
babies, and babies like to eat.
But I try to regularly
do a new experiment.
So another one I'm
doing probably in 2019--
this has already been announced,
it's not private info--
I'm doing a project with a
gay named Bryan Caplan who's
an economist.
I don't want to give
away too much, I guess.
But it's sort of
like a nonfiction,
pro-immigration
graphic novel trying
to explain some
statistics and stuff.
So that has been a totally
different challenge because I'm
just the Illustrator on it.
I can chat a little
with him about stuff,
but mostly i@m just
illustrating his words.
So that has been a completely
different challenge for me.
What I'm trying to
say is you should
do something that makes you
feel stupid at least like once
every two years.
Yeah, it's very important.
It's very important.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I feel like maybe you kind
of just answered my question,
but I guess what I was going to
say is you're both really great
communicators on complex
issues and complex topics.
And I was wondering if you
thought you might move more
in a direction of public
advocacy or public
information, which it kind of
sounds like you already maybe
are a little bit?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: A little bit.
I'm also working on
another comic project
I shouldn't say
too much about sort
of explaining political
norms, which suddenly people
are very interested in.
What did things used to be like?
A little bit more,
although I really do
enjoy fiction and
storytelling, so I don't want
to get too far away from that.
Part of the thing about having
a job explaining stuff is you
get to learn stuff all day long,
which is a pretty good deal
most of the time.
Sometimes it gets a little
thick, but most of the time
it's pretty awesome.
So for us, it's kind of a
lifestyle choice, I guess.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: One
thing that was also nice
about working as a
team is that one of us
would start doing the background
research, would write a draft,
and then we'd send
it to the other one.
And so, sometimes when you
get too thick into something,
it's easy to write it
and forget what you
didn't know when you started.
So if the other person
comes at it fresh,
they can tell you where you
haven't explained something
clearly.
And so we tried to work
the chapters like that.
And so that's one way we tried
to make everything clear,
which hopefully we did well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Kelly, I'm curious
about what some
of the other ideas Zach's
had that you thought
were the worst ones?
KELLY WEINERSMITH: That
made it in the book
that I thought were
particularly bad?
AUDIENCE: Either ones
that did or didn't.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Well, one of
the really interesting things
about writing this book was
that I went from thinking
some technologies were just
awesome across the board
to thinking they were awesome
but also kind of scary.
So asteroid mining, for example.
First of all, that one we
were totally wrong about what
asteroid mining was.
We thought the ideal was to
go out, get tungsten, bring it
to Earth, and now
have a ton of tungsten
that you can sell on earth.
But it turns out,
economically, that just
doesn't work because
you're going to bring
a ton of tungsten here.
You're going to
crash the market.
And then that was a waste
of billions and billions
of dollars.
And so the point now
is you go out there,
you get the tungsten,
you build a space base,
and then you go and
explore the world.
Or you bring it
the space station,
you get water from the
asteroids, blah blah blah.
But anyway, so we became really
excited about cheap access
to space and asteroid mining.
But the scary thing is, once
you get the ability to wrangle
asteroids and you can
bring them anywhere,
you can also fling them
at the Earth, which
could be worse than any nuclear
bomb we've ever set off.
And so when people get
cheap access to space--
for example, if the
space elevator works--
we suddenly will have tons
and tons of people in space.
Maybe we'll have
colonies on Mars.
And you'll suddenly have
people with the ability
to be able to move giant
objects and fling them
at Earth potentially.
And so it's a great
technology, but now you
have to trust that human
beings aren't horrible.
And I don't know if our
history totally warrants that.
And so it's a little bit scary.
It's an awesome technology
that now has something
that could be really negative.
And a lot of these
technologies are like that.
So our book originally had
advanced nuclear reactors--
fission reactors-- and
that's another technology
where it's like, well, if
you can trust everyone, then
that's great because we have
this greenhouse gas problem
that we want to get rid of.
Climate change is
obviously a bad thing
we're all dealing
with right now,
but can you trust
people with it?
Hard to say.
Does that kind of
answer your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: OK, great.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KELLY WEINERSMITH: Thanks.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Anything else?
KELLY WEINERSMITH:
Anything else?
OK.
Thank you very
much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]